[Musik]
Israel wurde die Lunte angezündet und
das Land explodierte auf den Straßen der
Großstädte gab es in den vergangenen
Monaten einige der größten Proteste in
der Geschichte des Landes mehr als
600.000 Menschen die Demokratie Riefen
und israelische Flaggen schwenken gegen
in Tel Aviv Jerusalem HIV und andere
Städten auf die Straße um gegen die
Regierung zu protestieren oder besser
gesagt gegen benjaminettan ja auch König
Bibi persönlich die Proteste begann im
Februar 2023 mit der Ankündigung einer
weitreichende Justizreform und wurden
nach und nach immer heftiger bis Ende
März die ganze Sache endgültig
eskalierte am Donnerstag den 23 März hat
die Knister das israelische Parlament
ein Gesetz verabschiedet das Netanjahus
macht vor gerichtlichen Maßnahmen
schützt dieses Gesetz verhindert
ausdrücklich dass der Oberste
Gerichtshof die Suspendierung eines
Ministerpräsidenten anordnen kann es
liegt fest dass nur eine dreiviertel
Mehrheit des Parlaments die
Suspendierung oder Absetzung des
Ministerpräsidenten erzwingen kann
dieses Gesetz und die große allgemein e
Unzufriedenheit mit einer höchst
umstrittenen absolut kritischen
Justizreform war so etwas wie der letzte
Tropfen der das Fass im jüdischen Staat
überlaufen ließ Autobahn lokarten
Polizei einsetzen mit Wasserwerfern
einer belagung von der Tanja aus
Privatwohnung in Jerusalem und ein
großer streite die wichtigsten Häfen und
den größten Flughafen des Landes sowie
Botschaften und Konsulate Lamm legte
obwohl die Proteste bisher überwiegend
friedlich und sehr geordert verlaufen
sind schien zeitweise alles darauf
hinzudeuten dass Israel am Rand eines
viel ernsteren sozialen Ausbruchs steht
einer Explosion die selbst zum Zeitpunkt
Erstellung dieses Videos nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen werden kann und nein wir
sind nicht die einzigen die so denken
seht euch mal folgendes an Ex
Befehlshaber der israelischen
Luftstreitkräfte eierf Netanyahu
erklärte den Bürgerkrieg ja es mag
übertrieben sein von einem Bürgerkrieg
zu sprechen aber die Wahrheit ist nun
mal dass die ideologische und religiöse
Spaltung sowie die Unzufriedenheit mit
der derzeitigen Politik die ein großer
Teil des Landes erlebt nur durch eine
scheinbare autoritätäre Version der
Tanja muss noch verstärkt wurde für
viele scheint König Bibi zu Gott Bibi
werden zu wollen aber wie konnte es
eigentlich dazu dass ein Premierminister
der den jüdischen Staat für den Großteil
dieses Jahr tausend gefühlt und enorme
wirtschaftliche und soziale Erfolge für
seine erzählt hat plötzlich in Ungnade
gefallen zu sein scheint
[Musik]
wir haben euch bereits in einem früheren
Video hier auf visualpolitik erklärt das
König Bibi der Architekt des modernen
Israels dieses Mal viele rote Linien
überschreiten könnte eine davon war eben
die Bildung einer Regierung mit
religiösen Fanatikern und einigen der
nationalistischsten radikalsten und
gefährlichsten Fraktion der israelischen
Politik die Rede ist natürlich von denen
die als extreme religiöse Zionisten
bekannt sind er hat sogar wenn wir zum
Minister für nationale Sicherheit
ernannt einen Mann den die Armee die
Militärdienst verweigert hat der Grund
er gehörte der faschistischen karpartei
an einer Gruppe die ihr werdet es nicht
glauben vom Staat Israel selbst als
terroristische Organisation eingestuft
und 1994 verboten wurde ja die Dinge in
dieser Regierung fingen wahrlich
schlecht an und sie scheinen jetzt immer
schlimmer zu werden seine Kritiker
behaupten Nathan Yahoo wurde zu weit
gehen und seine Machtposition im Staat
zu seinem eigenen persönlichen Vorteil
ausnutzen insbesondere werfen sie ihn
vor den Staat in einer persönliche
privatdomäne verwandeln zu wollen indem
er das Justizsystem reformiert um zu
kennenlernen das neue Gerichtsverfahren
gegen ihn angestrengt werden vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch ja noch daran dass mit
ein Yahoo in mehrere gerichtliche
Untersuchungen in Zusammenhang mit
angeblichen Korruptionsfällen verwickelt
ist oder war konkret ging es um vier
Fälle die als Fall
1000/3000 und Fall 4000 bekannt sind im
Fall 3000 bei denen es um den
angeblichen illegalen Kauf von deutschen
U-Booten gegen wurde er freigesprochen
aber die anderen drei Fälle werden noch
behandelt und auch sie sind nicht
unumstritten weil sie endlos erscheinen
10 Februar 2023 nach drei Jahren ist ein
Ende von Natalia aus Prozessen nicht in
Sicht einige Juristen sagen dass die
Richter in den italiano Fällen die
Verfahren zu lange hinauszögern nach
einer Haus eigener Ansicht und der
zahlreiche Russen aus seinem Umfeld
ziehen die Richter den Prozess
absichtlich in die Länge um ihn zu
schaden damit der Schatten der
Korruption weiterhin auf ihn fällt
doch abgesehen von möglichen
Spekulationen ist es eine Tatsache dass
es hochgradig umstritten war dass er die
Macht zurückerlangte indem er sich mit
der religiösen zionistischen Partei
Verbündete nach einer Koalitionsbildung
mit rechtsextremen und orthodoxen
Parteien mit rassistischen homophoben
und sogar kriegstreiberischen Untertönen
scheint die Justizreform nun wirklich zu
viel gewesen zu sein es war der Schritt
der einen großen Teil der israelischen
Gesellschaft dazu gebracht hat die
Geduld zu verlieren für ihre Gegner
stellt die Justizreform das Ende der
Demokratie in Israel da während ihrer
Befürworter behaupten dass gerade sie
die israelische Demokratie retten würde
alle werfen mit apokalyptischen Slogans
um sich Geburt des Autoritarismus hört
man von der einen Seite und das Ende der
richterlichen Tyrannei von der anderen
das hängt vor allem ab auf welche Seite
der israelischen Konfliktlinie sich
jemand befindet im Protein yahoulager
oder im Anti Tanja Hollager diejenigen
die dem ersten Lager angehören begrüßen
die Reform und die die den zweiten
Angehörigen lehnen Sie Wilhelm and ab
für die einen ist das Justiz perfekt und
braucht keine Reform für die anderen ist
es untragbar und muss komplett
umgekrempelt werden für beide Seiten
geht es um alles oder nichts also wer
hat nun Recht
und seine Koalitionspartner kritisieren
dass die Richter in Israel politisch
nicht neutral sein und der
rechtsgerichtete Regierung
unverhältnismäßig einschränken würden
die Justiz würde einen links gerichtete
politische Elite bilden die keiner
direkten demokratischen Kontrolle
unterliege im derzeitigen Form 30 Jahren
eingeführten verfassungsrahmen Israels
unterliegen alle Gesetze
regierungsanordnung und
Verwaltungsmaßnahmen staatlicher Stellen
der Überprüfung durch den Obersten
Gerichtshof dieser hat die Befugnis
Gesetze für ungültig zu erklären unsere
Regierungsentscheidungen rückgängig zu
machen wenn er feststellt dass sie gegen
Israels Grundgesetze verstoßen die Rolle
des Obersten Gerichtshofs wird von der
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung insbesondere
der politischen Linken als entscheidend
für die Wahrung einer ausgewogene
Demokratie und den Schutz der
Menschenrechte angesehen dass sie jedoch
liegt daran dass Israel ansonsten über
kein richtiges politisches Gegengewicht
zu Knister den Parlament verfügt diese
Rolle nimmt also quasi als Notlösung
eben der Oberste Gerichtshof ein die
obersten Richter werden dadurch in eine
politische Rolle gedrängt die in anderen
Ländern beispielsweise eine ein
Parlamentskammer eine Präsidenten mit
Exekutivgewalt föderalen bzw regionalen
Repräsentanten oder auch eine
überstaatlichen Organisation wieder EU
zufällt das Problem dabei die Richter am
Obersten Gerichtshof werden durch eine
Gremium ernannt indem man nicht
demokratisch gewählte Richter und
Anwälte die Mehrheit stellen und dies
hat mit der Zeit dazu geführt dass ich
eine rekursives System etabliert hat das
zu Bildung eines in sich geschlossenen
Zirkels aus Vertretern der Justiz führte
dieser Zirkel stimmt meist koordiniert
ab und lässt dadurch nicht zu dass
Kandidaten mit abweichenden Auffassungen
aufgenommen werden man will nun mal
keine Abweichler neben sich auf der
Richter Bank sitzen haben aber auch der
Weg auf dem dieses System etabliert
wurde hat ein gewisses geschmackle
normalerweise erfolgen Änderung des
Regierungssystems eines Landes als
Ergebnis einer demokratischen Einigung
in Israel kam dieses Systemänderung
jedoch durch ein höchst ungewöhnliches
und Überraschendes Gerichtsurteil
Zustande alles fängt damit an dass die
knistert 1992 Grundgesetze mit Bezug zum
Menschenrechten verabschiedete das erste
wurde dabei in einem 120-köpfigen
Parlament mit nur 26 ja stimmen und das
zweite mit 32 Stimmen angenommen aus den
Debatten in der Knesset geht hervor dass
sich viele Abgeordnete überhaupt nicht
darüber bewusst waren dass diese neuen
Gesetze verfassungsrechtlich verankerte
Rechte betreffen oder den Status der
richterlichen Überprüfungen Israel
beeinflussen der damalige Vorsitzende
des verfassungsunterrichtsausschusses
Versicherte seinen Abgeordneten vor der
Abstimmung sogar ausdrücklich folgendes
wir räumen den Obersten Gerichtshof
damit kein größeres Gewicht ein es gibt
keinen Platz für ein Verfassungsgericht
das durch dieses Gesetz besondere
Befugnisse zum Aufheben von
Rechtsvorschriften erhält uriellen
ehemaliger Liquid Abgeordneter in der
knisse im Jahr 1992 das Problem israel
hat keine formelle Verfassung denn eine
Verfassung ist ein von der Bürgerschaft
durch ihre Vertreter angenommene Text er
die Spielregeln auf der politischen
Bühne festlegt und der nicht die andere
Gesetze durch eine einfache politische
Mehrheit geändert werden kann Gesetze
mit Verfassungsfragen müssen durch eine
viel breitere gesellschaftliche Mehrheit
abgesegnet werden dies erfolgt in
anderen Ländern zum Beispiel durch zwei
Drittel Mehrheiten oder durch mehrere
parlamentarische Kammern in Israel ist
die sie noch nie geschehen und
ironischerweise war es ausgerechnet der
erste Ministerpräsident Israels Ben
David guerion der bei der Staatsgründung
verhinderte dass eine ordentliche
Verfassung verabschiedet wurde er
befürchtete nämlich dass die damals eher
konservativen obersten Richter seines
sozialistische Agenda behindern würden
ja genau damals war es ein Linker
Politiker der die Macht rechter Richter
beschneiden wollt und heute reimt sich
die Geschichte in Israel aber eben nur
andersherum und aus diesem Grund gibt es
heute in Israel keine formelle
Verfassung oder auch kein formelles
Verfassungsgericht sondern nur ein
oberstes Gericht das Problem dieses
oberste Gericht übt ohne eine
verfassungsmäßige Grundlage seit 30
Jahren eine Macht aus über die
eigentlich nur ein Verfassungsgericht
verfügen sollte gut aber wie kam es
eigentlich dazu wurde den Knete
Abgeordneten damals nicht versichert die
neuen Grundgesetze würden kein
Verfassungsgericht erschaffen nun am 9
November 1995 nur 5 Tage nach der
Ermordung von terminminister karabin
veröffentlichte der Oberste Gerichtshof
einen dramatisches Urteil im sogenannten
Bank missraten Fall der damalige
Gerichtspräsident Barak entschieden
zusammen mit einer Mehrheit der Richter
das den bis dahin erlassenen Grundlagen
gesätzen ein höherer Verfassungsrang als
anderen gesessen oder
Regierungsmaßnahmen Weg einzuräumen sei
und dass die 1992 erlassen den beiden
Grundgesetze höherwertige Grundgesetze
bildeten und somit die Verfassung für
alle rechtlichen Zwecke
wenn den Richtern bisher konventionelle
Waffen zur Verfügung standen um sich mit
der Gesetzgebung durch Auslegung und die
Schaffung von israelischem
Gewohnheitsrecht zu befassen haben die
Richter nun nicht konventionelle Waffen
erhalten die es ermöglichen Gesetze die
nicht in Kriterien der Grundgesetze
entsprechend für nichtig zu erklären
acharon Barak Präsident des Obersten
Gerichts in Israel von 1995 bis 2006 mit
anderen Worten Barack und seine Kollegen
erklärten einfach dass der Oberste
Gerichtshof von nun an jede Gesetzgebung
oder Politik aufheben kann die ihrer
Meinung nach Widerspruch zu einem
Grundgesetz steht und zwar entsprechend
ihrer eigenen Ansicht und Auslegung die
obersten Richter Kürten sich im Rahmen
einer sogenannten konstitutionellen
Revolution selbst zu Verfassungsrecht
dann ohne das ist in der Praxis eine
formelle Verfassung gäbe sie fühlten
auch sehr eigenwillige und pragmatische
Weise dass demokratische Vakuum das
politische Loch das bandorium bei der
Staatsgründung hinterlassen hatte und
dass die Politiker bislang nicht zu
stopfen in der Lage waren Israel bekam
somit durch die Hintertür eine etwas
etwas komische fließende Verfassung die
im wesentlichen das Weltbild der Richter
widerspiegelt und die Anhänger der
netanjahischen Justizreform behaupten
deswegen dass die Realität in Israel
deswegen heute überspritzt formuliert so
aussehen würde dass es 15 Richter gibt
die sich gegenseitig selbst auswählen
und die das letzte Wort in allen Fragen
der öffentlichen Ordnung haben tja
klingt nicht super doll demokratisch
nicht wahr und zwar ebenso wie das
Defizit in der Gewaltenteilung das ist
schon vorher gab und das wird dann ja
und nun wieder anstrebt das keines
dieser Modelle ideal ist zeigt auch der
Vergleich mit dem Ausland in 24 von 36
OSI Ländern werden Richter von
demokratisch gewählten Vertretern
ernannt beispiele dafür sind die USA
Deutschland und Frankreich neben Israel
gibt es nur 4 OC die Mitgliedstaaten die
Richter ohne demokratische Legitimation
ändern das sind die Türkei Griechenland
Großbritannien und Luxemburg allerdings
haben in Großbritannien Luxemburg und
den meisten anderen Staaten die Richter
keine Macht Gesetze des Parlaments für
ungültig zu erklären deswegen
argumentierte Tanja oder sie macht
unterrichte ein Israel auch im
internationalen Maßstab viel zu weit
gehe und die direkt gewählten Vertreter
des Volkes in der Legislative im
Zweifelsfall immer das letzte Wort haben
sollten und theoretisch klingt das was
er sagt eigentlich erst einmal nicht
grundverkehrt der Haken an der ganzen
Geschichte die geplante Reform geht weit
über vorsichtige Änderungen an der Macht
Balance zwischen der Judikative und in
anderen Gewalten im Staat der hinaus es
handelt sich viel mehr wie wir euch im
Detail aufzeigen werden um einen Versuch
der totalen Unterwerfung der Judikative
durch die Regierung netanjahoo kippt mit
dem Baden nämlich gleich das ganze Kind
namens Justiz aus er nutzt die Defizite
in der israelischen Verfassungsordnung
dazu aus um sich eigene Vorteile zu
verschaffen wir sprechen über eine
Reform die in wesentlichen darauf
abzielt den Premierminister in seiner
Position abzuschauen und es der
Regierung zu ermöglichen dass
Justizsystem stärker direkt zu
kontrollieren und wenn wir von Kontrolle
sprechen meinen wir damit nicht dass da
auch fragwürdige Art und Weise ein paar
Gleichgesinnte Richter hier und da
platziert werden die die Regierung in
jedem Moment aus ihren Schwierigkeit
Seiten befreien können nein wir sprechen
von einer viel viel umfassenden
Kontrolle von der viele glauben dass sie
die einzige liberale Demokratie im Nahen
Osten wirklich in die Knie zwingen
könnte
netanjaho ging nun einfach zu weit
Benjamin der Tanja husreformen lösen in
den USA Gegenreaktion von glühenden
Israel Anhängern aus die Reform ist
notwendig und wir werden sie durchführen
aber nicht um den Preis eines
Bürgerkriegs Nürnberger hat israelische
Wirtschaftsminister auf dem Tisch liegt
eine Reform der die umstritten
justizänderung von orbanen Ungarn und
die ist in Polen vergleichsweise harmlos
aussehen lassen würde ja neben diese
wirklich wie totale Amateure in der
zweifelhaften Kunst die Justiz an die
kurze Leine nehmen zu wollen aber welche
Punkte sind es genau die so viele
Israelis gegen diese Veränderung
mobilisiert haben was genau umfasst ihre
Form die netanjah früher oder später
verabschieden will und warum sind
eigentlich erst Ende März die Proteste
auf den Straßen gegen die Regierung
eskaliert all das und noch viel mehr
verraten euch in diesem Video bevor wir
loslegen möchte ich euch aber noch gerne
darum bitten nicht zu vergessen dass ihr
unsere Arbeit mit Hilfe eurer
freiwilligen Spenden maßgeblich
unterstützen können wenn euch also
unsere Videos gefallen und vielleicht
sogar einen Mehrwert bringen wären wir
euch für einen kleinen Beitrag über den
Spenden Link in der Videobeschreibung
findet sehr sehr dankbar so und wenn ihr
dies erledigt habt schnallt euch schnell
an der begeben uns auf eine Reise nach
Israel einem Land in dem der volkszone
massiv hoch kocht
[Musik]
Reform der Zwietracht
es gibt etwas von den jeder in Israel
eine Vorahnung hatte aber vielleicht
haben nicht so viele Menschen gedacht
dass es so eklatant eintreten würde ja
es war bekannt das Internet an die Macht
zurückzukehren das Streben nach
bestimmten persönlichen Vorteilen stand
aber nur wenige hätten sich vorstellen
können dass Bibi innerhalb weniger
Monate nach seiner Rückkehr an die Macht
und hat in Hand mit einigen der
radikalsten Parteien in der politischen
Geschichte Israels so weit gehen würde
und die Wahrheit ist nun mal meine
Lieben Zuschauer dass die Reform die
direkt von Lego Justizminister Jahre
leben vorangetrieben wird aber auch von
seinen radikalen regierungspartnern
unterstützt und gefördert wird es der
israelischen Exekutive ermöglichen würde
die Judikative fast vollständig zu
kontrollieren aber schauen wir uns doch
mal an was genau auf dem Spiel steht
nun zum einen steht hinter der Reform
die Idee dass die Entscheidungen des
obersten gerätshofs strikt der
politischen Macht untergeordnet werden
die vorgeschlagene Reform erhöht zum
Beispiel die notwendigen Anforderungen
um Gesetze für illegal zu erklären und
bereits verabschiedete Gesetze
aufzuheben aber das ist natürlich nicht
das Schlimmste wenn der Oberste
Gerichtshof eingesetzt dennoch für
ungültig erklärt kann die Knister das
Parlament diese Entscheidung mit einer
einfachen Mehrheit von 61 der insgesamt
120 Stimmen aufheben das heißt dass die
Entscheidungen des Obersten Gerichtshofs
von der politischen Macht leicht
rückgängig gemacht werden könnten wenn
sie ihren Interessen zuwiderlaufen dies
würde der parlamentarischen Mehrheit
praktisch unbegrenzte Macht geben und
die Judikative als Kontrollinstanz
entfernen aber wenn ihr das schon für
undemokratisch halte dann wartet ab was
jetzt kommt der Gesetzesentwurf sieht
nämlich auch vor dem Obersten
Gerichtshof die Befugnis zu entziehen
die Rechtmäßigkeit der israelischen
Grundgesetze zu überprüfen wir sprechen
hier von Gesetzen die die eine Art
Verfassung auf Raten funktionieren wie
gesagt in Israel gibt es im Gegensatz zu
den meisten anderen Ländern der Welt
keine ordentlich verabschiedete
Verfassung der Staat wird stattdessen
von einer Reihe von grundgesetzten
regiert die verabschiedet und reformiert
werden und die Reform wurde
offensichtlich dazu führen dass die
aktuell an der Macht befindlichen
politischen Parteien mit einfacher
Mehrheit fast alles oder jeden
ungeheuerlichen Rechtsvorschlag an die
Spitze des israelischen Rechtssystems
stellen könnten und der Oberste
Gerichtshof könnte praktisch nichts
dagegen tun aber nein selbst das ist
noch nicht das Ende der veranstange es
kommt noch mehr
natürlich wäre eine gute Justizreform
zur Kontrolle der Gerichte nicht
vollständig wenn man nicht auch die
Richter kontrollieren würde und nein
auch dieser Punkt wird im Gesetzentwurf
nicht vergessen die Reform sieht auch
Änderungen in der Art und Weise vor wie
Richter gewählt werden insbesondere
sollen die Befugnisse des Richter
Wahlausschusses geändert werden wer für
die Ernennung der Richter an
israelischen Gerichten zuständig ist
derzeit setzt sich wie gesagt diese
Ausschuss aus einer bunten Mischung aus
Regierungsmitgliedern Politikern und
Juristen zusammen um sicherzustellen
dass keine der drei Gruppen jemals einen
Mehrheit hat wenn es darum geht eine
Entscheidung zu treffen das Ziel der
Reform ist es zwei Vertreter der
israelischen Anwaltskammer zu eliminiert
auf diese Weise hätten die Vertreter der
Regierung oder der Regierungskoalition 5
von 9 Stunden die Kontrolle über die
Ernennung von Richtern Legenden effektiv
in den Händen der Regierung
tja in der Tat schon ein fast totalitär
durchtriebener Plan und es geht nicht
nur um Richter die Idee das Rechtssystem
zu politisieren erreicht alle Ebenen
auch die Rechtsberater das Gremium der
staatlichen Rechtsberater in Israel
besteht heute aus mehr oder weniger
unabhängigen Fachleuten die dem
Generalstaatsanwalt unterstellt sind
ihre Entscheidungen sind bis zu einem
gewissen Grad bindend mit anderen Worten
um politische Änderungen vorzunehmen
muss die Regierung die Zustimmung der
Rechtsberater einholen sie muss auf
diese Weise sicherstellen dass das was
sie tut als legal angesehen werden kann
nach der Reform wäre auch das nicht mehr
der Fall diese Rechtsberater könnten
willkürlich von Politikern eingestellt
oder gefeuert werden und ihre Kriterien
wären nicht mehr als unverbindliche
Empfehlungen und dies würde dazu führen
dass die Regierung auch dann Maßnahmen
ergreifen kann wenn sie weiß dass sie
illegal sind ja eine Film der Böse ist
dabei denkt man hat also offensichtlich
wirklich an alles gedacht
meine Lieben besucherpolitik Zuschauer
das sind einige der schwerwiegendsten
Postulate der von Bibi angeführten
Justizreform und sicherlich versteht ihr
jetzt viel besser die enorme Empörung
die Sie sowohl innerhalb als auch
außerhalb des Landes ausgelöst hat wir
lieben Israel aber wir werden nicht
zusehen wie Israels demokratische
Grundlagen geschwächt wenn ich gar
untergraben werden wir können uns keine
jüdischen Stadt vorstellen der nicht
demokratisch ist und doch gibt es Leute
die das können Rabi Jacobs Präsident der
Union für ihre Form Judentum die
Proteste haben Bibi dazu veranlasst das
Gesetz vorläufig einzufrieren das hat
den übrigens die Konzession gekostet
dass der extremistische Minister für
nationale Sicherheit ETA Mal wenn wir
seine eigene Prätorianer Garde
aufstellen darf das bedeutet dass die
Nationalgarde auf 1800 Soldaten
verdoppelt und direkt diesen Minister
unterstellt wird um die Verzögerungen
bei der Überarbeitung zu kompensieren
erhält benediktier die Zusage für eine
Nationalgarde unter seiner Kontrolle
Kritiker kritisieren dass wenn wir damit
eine private Miliz erhalte nun stellt
sich die Frage was Bibi mit all dem
eigentlich wirklich bezweckt
offensichtlich zielt der Gesetzentwurf
zu Justizreform direkt darauf ab den
Obersten Gerichtshof zu schwächen um den
Premierminister die Möglichkeit zu geben
Richter unter Druck zu setzen tja
eventuell mit der Hoffnung dass sie dann
die Korruptionsverfahren gegen den
einfrieren oder sogar eine stellen und
wie ihr euch sicher vorstellen könnt hat
das nicht nur auf der Straße sondern
auch auf politischer Ebene Konsequenzen
nach sich gezogen zum Beispiel sprach
sich als Verteidigungsminister gegen die
von seinem Parteikollegen nataliao
vorangetriebene Reformhaus
habe ich dutzende Male mein Leben für
den Staat Israel riskiert und in diesem
Moment bin ich bereit für unser Land
jedes Risiko einzugehen und jeden Preis
zu zahlen ich erkläre laut und
öffentlich das und der Sicherheit
Israels Willen um unserer Söhne und
Töchter wählen das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren gestoppt werden
muss ja Land Verteidigungsminister
Israels der Verteidigungsminister
forderte seinen eigenen Chef also
tatsächlich auf den Prozess
Verabschiedung der Justizreform zu
stoppen woraufhin Nathan Yahoo prompt
seine Entlassung verkündete dies führte
wiederum zu massiven Protesten in
zahlreichen großen Städten des Landes
und am 10 April hat nicht dann
jahrhundert Zähne knirschen verkündet
dass er sich das mit der Entlassung doch
anders überlegt habe galant bleibt im
Amt tatsächlich ist er Widerstand gegen
die Reform innerhalb von Israel
überlebenswichtigen Sicherheitskräfte
besonders stark ja fast schon militant
dies ist der wichtigste Krieg meines
Lebens wir befinden uns mitten in einem
Gesetzgebungsprozess der wie ein
gepanzerter den neuen Bulldozer daher
kommt und die Justiz überrollt wir
befinden uns in einer Wirtschaftskrise
und werden bald in eine sicherheitskrise
geraten Moschee ja Alon ehemaliger
Verteidigungsminister Israels mehr als
400 ehemalige hochrangige Sicherheit
Beamte darunter ehemalige Leiter der
israelischen Polizei des schien Bett und
es muss halt haben in einem offenen
Brief den Präsidenten des Landes
aufgefordert keine Gesetze zu
unterzeichnen die den demokratischen
Grundwerten Israels widersprechen die
unterstütztere Form sei ein juristischer
Kuh der eine Tragödie für zukünftige
Generation verursachen würde der
ehemalige generalstoffchef der
israelischen Streitkräfte dann hallo uns
behauptet er weil das ist aufgrund von
massenhaften Fällen von
Wehrdienstverweigerung kommen würde der
Grund Israelis werden nur bereit eine
Demokratie zu verteidigen nicht eine
Diktatur und tatsächlich haben hunderte
von Armee Offizieren also wissen
Luftwaffen Piloten und sogar aktive
Mitglieder der Geheimdienste
Position unterschrieben und zum Beispiel
streikspaar übungsmissionen angekündigt
der Dienst in der Direktion vor
Sondereinsätze erfordert eine
vollständige Übereinstimmung mit den
Werten des Staates und eine furchtlose
Gedankenfreiheit Dinge die verschwinden
wenn wir zu einer Diktatur werden
Petition aus den israelischen
geheimdienstor wir haben hier auch
Politik schon in einer unserer ersten
Videos über die militärische Stärke
Israel herausgestellt dass der große
Vorteil der IDF eben in der starken
Identifikation das Soldaten mit den
demokratischen Werten ihres Staates
zusammenhängt ich werde euch das Video
verlinken damit ihr es euch anschließend
ansehen könnt denn das Schlimmste ist
dass dies alles wirklich zu einer Unzeit
kommt in der das Land aufgrund der
offensichtlichen Fortschritte die der
Iran bei der Entwicklung seines
Programms macht eine sehr angespannte
Zeit in Sachen Sicherheit durchlebt aber
die Justizreform hat findet dann ja auch
scheinbar Vorrang vor allem anderen er
spielt tatsächlich mit dem Feuer die
angedrohte Entlassung des
Verteidigungsministers die zu allem
Überfluss auch noch von den Ultra
rechtsorddroxen Regierungspartner muss
man beim Gebirge unterstützt wurde der
buchstäblich den Herausforderung Balance
aus der Regierung forderte ist keine
Kleinigkeit für bentons Partei die sich
für den Ausbau der jüdischen Siedlungen
investieren Land einsetzt könnte Natalia
Haus vorgeschlagene Justizreform auch
bedeuten dass sie freie Hand für ihre
politischen Ambitionen in den arabisch
palästinesischen Gebieten erhält dann
wäre es zum Beispiel viel einfacher neue
Siedlungen zu errichten da das Gericht
das über ihre Legalität entscheiden
müsste keine wirkliche Macht hätte sie
so stoppen
und obwohl er dann seine Justizreform
erstmal verschoben hat um sich eine
gewisse Ruhe auf den Straßen
zurückzukaufen
Natalia wo setzt Justizreform aus ich
werde Israel nicht in einen Bürgerkrieg
führen hat er dennoch auch gesagt dass
er ihre Form früher oder später sowieso
durchziehen würde das Ausmaß
antwortesten sieht er als legitim an und
zitiert hierzu ausgerechnet unseren
alten Freund
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Israels das Recht
zu demonstrieren ist ein grundlegender
demokratischer wert aber die Freiheit zu
demonstrieren ist nicht die Freiheit das
Land zum Stillstand zu bringen derjenige
der das vor 20 Jahren gesagt hat war der
ehemalige Präsident des Obersten
Gerichtshof ach Herr Hornbach es war
damals richtig und es ist auch heute
richtig die Freiheit zu demonstrieren
ist kein Freibrief das Land in die
Anarchie ins Chaos zu treiben denn als
souveränes Land kann keine anarchieden
wenn ihr mir dann ja damit hatten
jahrhundert natürlich recht allerdings
darf man darüber nicht vergessen dass
die Gründe aus denen er seinen brachial
Reform zu nicht so kompromisslos
durchdrücken wollte äußerst fragwürdig
sind zum einen verfolgt der eigene und
lautere Interessen aufgrund der
Korruptionsfälle gegen ihn und zum
anderen steht er unter Druck seine
extremistischen Verbündeten in der
Regierung die anscheinend bereit während
Bibi selbst wieder in den Ruhestand oder
sogar ins Gefängnis zu schenken wenn
Ihre Vorstellungen nicht umgesetzt
werden ja es ist klar dass ihm selbst
das Wasser bis zum Hals steht aber in
dem mit deinen Jahren mit dem breche
Reisen gegen die Justiz vorgeht setzt er
nicht nur sein eigenes Erbe Aufspiel
sondern er weist auch seinem Land
langfristig einen Bärendienst natürlich
ist israelsystem der Gewaltenteilung ein
zweischneidiges Schwert und
reformbedürftig da der Oberste
Gerichtshof über keine ausreichende
demokratische Legitimation verfügt aber
trotzdem Gesetze und
Regierungsentscheidungen rückgängig
machen kann besteht die Gefahr dass
seine Entscheidung von vielen Menschen
in Frage gestellt werden dadurch wird
die Gesellschaft unnötig polarisiert und
gespalten und das Vertrauen großer Teile
der Bevölkerung in das politische und in
das Justizsystem untergraben und dies
ist sicherlich etwas dass sich Israel
auch bestimmten Gebieten wie z.B der
Sicherheit langfristig existenziell
nicht leisten kann die starke Position
des Obersten Gerichtshofs kann dazu
führen das politische Gruppen versuchen
die Gerichtsentscheidungen zu
beeinflussen um ihre eigenen Interessen
durchzusetzen was auch nicht gerade die
Qualität der Demokratie im Lande erhöht
daher wäre es wichtig und richtig eine
Justizreform auf den Weg zu bringen die
auf einem breiten konsistente
Bevölkerung basiert nur dies würde auch
langfristig eine stabilen
verfassungsrahmen garantiert die von der
Regierung netaniano vorgeschlagen
Änderungen wurden nur dazu führen dass
die nächste Regierung entweder auch zu
viel unkontrollierte macht bekommt oder
die Reform einfach wieder einkassiert
und wir alle wissen ja wie kurz die
Halbwertszeit einer israelischen
Regierung ist nicht wahr wie also würde
eine gesunde Reform Aussehen nun um die
demokratische Legitimation bei der
Ernennung von Richtern zu erhöhen könnte
das System Sura formiert werden das
gewählte Vertreter stärker beteiligt
werden beispielsweise könnte die
kniszeit oder ein dafür zuständiges
Komitee des Mitglieder von der Knister
gewählt werden eine größere Rolle bei
der Änderung von Richtern spielen
allerdings sollte sich dadurch keine
automatische Mehrheit haben und es
sollte auch darauf geachtet werden dass
sie Unabhängigkeit ist die gewahrt
bleibt und politische Einflussnahme
minimiert wird dies könnte man zum
Beispiel gewährleisten indem man eine
verbindliche Amtszeit für richtetes
Obersten Gerichtshofs eingeführt wird
dadurch wurde verhindert das Richter
auch unbestimmte Zeiten bleiben oder
umgekehrt politischen Druck ausgesetzt
sind weil sie abgerufen werden können um
sicherzustellen dass die Auswahl der
Richter nach objektiven Kriterien
erfolgt könnte das Auswahlverfahren
transparenter gestaltet und definierte
Kriterien für die Auswahl von Kandidaten
festgelegt werden alternativ oder gar
parallel zur Justizreform Günther Israel
natürlich auch eine Reform der
Legislative angehen um das System der
check-in-balances auf ein solides
demokratisches Fundament zu stellen
könnte man zum Beispiel über die
Einführung eines 2 kammersystems
nachdenken schließlich ist Israel
mittlerweile 75 Jahre alt stark
gewachsen und hat sich extrem gewandelt
man kann die 8 Millionen Einwohner nicht
mit ein paar hunderttausenden von 1948
vergleichen um die andere demokratische
Staaten vergleichbarer Größe und
Struktur zu werden sind umfassendere
Formen daher unabdingbar wir bleiben auf
jeden Fall am Ball und werden euch über
jegliche Anzeichen auf dem Laufenden
halten momentan ist von ihnen es war
noch nicht viel zu sehen aber das kann
sich durchaus ändern schließlich dürfen
wir nicht vergessen dass die Israelis
ein unglaublich streitlustiges Volk sind
in dem sich die vielen
verschiedenen Ergebnis zu kommen
vielleicht ist auch dieser Straße
verbissen er nach außen aussehen mag im
Kern doch
konstruktiv eine Hoffnung existiert ihr
auf jeden Fall denn nach all den
massenprotestungen Generalstreiks
kündigte Tanja Hoya an die
Verabschiedung des Gesetzes zur
neugestattung des Richter
wallausschusses erst einmal nicht weiter
zu forcieren bis die größten
Kritikpunkte im Dialog mit den
Oppositionskräften geklärt sind und
deswegen könnt ihr jetzt auch erstmal im
Kommentarbereich konstruktiv diskutieren
was haltet ihr von der durch die
israelische Regierung vorgeschlagene
Justizreform wird netanjahoo sie so
knallhaft durchziehen wie angekündigt
glaubt ihr dass dies das endgültige Ende
von der Tanja aus Karriere bedeuten
könnte würde am Ende vielleicht gar im
Knast landen oder wird sich das Land
doch noch auf einen breiten Kompromiss
einigen wie sollte eine gute umfassende
Reform für Israel aussehen und wie steht
es in eurem Land um die demokratische
Gewaltenteilung wie immer sind doch
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt hat wenn ja
geht uns bitte ein Like heißt mit euren
Freunden vergiss nicht das Abo mit
glücklich und keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich von 19 jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit diesem
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung
macht's gut bis bald und Shalom
[Musik]